so my fam is a lifestyle entrepreneur
with almost 3 million subscribers who
dropped out of school at 15 years old
moved alone to New York City and built
her entire career with just a camera
today she opens up for the first time
about a rocky upbringing I've actually
never told this story ever and how she
was able to turn her passion into a
million dollar business while being a
teenager so with that said enjoy and
let's get to the podcast
wait hold on one sec hey Jack what's up
yo Graham just calling to let you know I
will not be back in town for a few more
days since I'm still visiting family
also dude I've been spending a ton of
time with my brother and his girlfriend
and I feel like I'm just consistently
third wheeling and it's making me
realize I really want a girlfriend but I
also don't really know where to find the
right one well Jack luckily for you
match reached out to sponsor today's
episode match is a dating app that
allows you to customize your profile to
meet people that you're actually
compatible with unlike other dating apps
where you can match with someone whose
profile is limited to two blurry photos
and no bio match actually gives you
useful information about the person and
their personality Jack get this being in
a relationship can actually help save
you more money match recently did a
study of over 5000 singles and found
that being single has gotten
significantly more expensive over the
last decade in fact over 30 percent of
singles said that they prefer a chill
easy and most importantly free first
date uh Graham I'm still here having the
match app is one of the best ways to put
yourself out there while also
maintaining a busy schedule the best
relationships tend to come about once
you're focusing on yourself and there's
never been a better time to try match so
feel free to use our link Down Below in
the description to get started today hi
welcome back to the iced coffee chant no
welcome back to the iced coffee hour not
Channel hour
thanks so much for coming on bye oh
thank you for having me I'm so excited
to be in Vegas and also in this crazy
podcast room thank you so much for
coming it's funny how this turned out
but uh I watched a video of you living
alone in New York City that I reacted to
I really enjoyed the video your videos
got so many views for the living alone
series yes and I reacted to it and I
think I apologize for this my video
reacting to your video got more views in
your videos
don't rub it in my face I'm sorry if you
wouldn't notice oh really yeah it was a
good video though it was a good video
yeah yeah your reactions really made it
what do you think though I enjoy listen
I really enjoy your content you have a
very like Emma Chamberlain sort of style
where it's where it's it's entirely
personality based and the fact that you
could be home like doing nothing but
still making entertaining for 10 to 15
minutes for people to watch and a lot of
people watch I think is really cool
thank you how did you start with with
this my channel dates all the way back
until I think 2010 so in 2010 I think I
was seven years old or something like
that and growing up I had like Asian
immigrant parents so they're very like
musical like you know what I mean piano
guitar you always hear that kind of
stuff so they always put me in these
classes so I would have to do singing
lessons and I was like oh okay I'm gonna
be a musician one day I always knew as a
kid I wanted to be in some sort of
entertainment so I started a YouTube
channel because I didn't know how to
express myself so I started making like
webcam videos of me singing and covers
and they're still on YouTube to this day
and then after that I progressed into
like more
I don't know like Minecraft like MCSG PC
gaming because my brother used to build
PC so I did some streams and all that
stuff and then it kind of progressed
into High School Vlogs and then I guess
where I am now that's right so hold up
your parents are okay with you making a
YouTube channel they didn't know that's
the thing like they had no idea but the
thing is like I was always on my laptop
inside and like learning like new things
and this is when YouTube just came out
but the reason why I had a laptop was
because my parents were like okay well
they're well they were very strict
parents okay so they were very strict in
different types of ways I wasn't allowed
to go outside and hang out with friends
and I wasn't allowed to go on walks
outside I wasn't allowed to like you
would hang out with go on Halls yeah
like they said too so safe right very
safe like I grew up in a small town
um and like there was not very much like
you know what I mean not it wasn't
dangerous basically but they just didn't
let me outside because they were
traditional and like you should be
driven around like you shouldn't walk
like I never walked anywhere as a kid
because my grandma it wasn't my parents
taking care of me it was my grandma my
parents were always at work so she was
there and she would always drive us
everywhere which was super nice but you
know you lose the freedom of being able
to go to the park or being able to just
like be a kid and be outside you know
which I know that sounds crazy but
that's how my YouTube channel started
was because since I couldn't talk to
like friends
um like I don't know like in real life
because I wasn't allowed to do the
things that kids do I went to like
Minecraft and I went to YouTube to like
talk to people and I would add people on
Skype and like literally be on my
computer all day long as a kid it's
interesting that they were so strict
about you not going outside or seeing
friends but uploading YouTube videos as
a kid was okay yeah I think honestly
they didn't even know that stuff existed
do you know what I mean like they were
so in like they are like Asian immigrant
parents like they're not thinking about
the internet you know what I mean so
they didn't realize like what a laptop
could have they just think oh like you
know what I mean games
but they honestly didn't even understand
YouTube until maybe like four years ago
three years ago but I've been doing this
like 12 years so how do you think that
upbringing shape to you today I think it
really correlates to my YouTube videos
like there's a lot of living alone and
what people don't understand when they
view those videos is that like the
reason why I've had so many of those
series is because I was kind of like
forced into being independent because
like I didn't voluntarily like
want to live alone at such a young age
obviously like I'm so grateful and I
love it like I wouldn't have chose for
anything better like this is like a life
that I like have always dreamed of doing
but I didn't choose to like move out
when I was 15 you know what I mean so
it's just like people don't see that
kind of side of me yeah could you tell
us about that experience moving out of
15. yeah I've actually never told this
story ever wow I've never told this
story because like I don't know like why
would I make a whole video about like my
upbringing like that just sounds sad and
like sappy you know what I mean yeah but
I think people would really respect that
and like really I feel transparent
people want that from you and just and
feel that connection with you because of
because of how open you are really yeah
I'm like you girl like why like in my
head I'm like if I made a whole video
about that being like the real reason
why I moved out of 15 like that's so
dramatic it's just like girl like we're
here for some entertainment tell us some
jokes like we don't want to hear yes
that's what goes on in my head I think
it's the demeanor so like you could
title it something kind of sad but then
in the video yeah it's whatever you know
I moved out when I was 15. it's not a
big deal right I'd kind of make up for
it no but that's like what I always say
I'm always like yeah like I was sleeping
with my friends couch it and I always
joke about it but people were always
like what like they don't actually
understand because I joke about all the
time because I don't want to get sad
about it
but okay but all right let's spill it oh
you guys want to know yeah we want to
know yeah yeah 100 no you guys wanted to
know yeah uh should I get the tea
grit don't say that
I'm trying I'm learning oh wow you're
doing good I I am really proud of you no
you're really reaching my demographic
you know like the 18 to like 24 year old
girls you're really reaching I'm trying
18 to 24 year old girls are watching yes
interesting no but then like I like that
audience it's interesting wait what's
your guys's demographic 18 to 35 85 guys
yeah guys okay so maybe like we can do
like the like a bachelorette like kind
of dating show but like show art
demographics that's great Finance Bros
and like um Wellness girls
in heaven yeah all right I like that so
okay I'll not use the word tea anymore
no I I you know what I'm proud of you I
think it's a good chance just trying
decision there just trying you'll see me
at 50 like you know we're still going
all the cool kids yeah I'll copy their
outfits and stuff that'll be great man
anyway out of you okay you guys want to
know why I'm your dad when I was a team
okay I like made a video once when I was
younger when I was actually like I don't
know 16 so there wasn't like not a lot
of time had processed and people were
just wondering why I went from like
living with my parents to living on my
own so I put out like a [ __ ] video
it wasn't [ __ ] it was so truthful
but I was just basically saying like oh
yeah like I just choose to move out when
I was 15 there was nothing wrong with me
my parents because like I'm they're
still my parents like why would I say
that you know and like it was just
freshly happening so a lot of people
were like oh that's the reason why she
wasn't actually kicked out so that's
what's been servicing for the past
couple years that I've never actually
told people why
sit back relax put the Buckle seat on
okay Buckle seat seat belt seat belt
buckle seat buckle CC belt okay
[Music]
um
the airbag turned on the airbag turned
on okay turn on the aircraft in case I
feel like this is like a story time that
I'm doing right now I'm excited to hear
that yeah this is a podcast not a story
time y'all you know what you know you if
you want to share this okay basically
just sum it up like I didn't have a very
good upbringing with my family so we
would always get in arguments and stuff
like that or just like you know people
have family issues and I remember me and
my dad hadn't didn't have the best
relationship so like we would just get
in arguments over the littlest things
and one day he was like oh clean your
room in the morning and all this stuff
which is so funny because now I make I
have this series called cleaning my room
at 2AM so it's so crazy that the reason
why I got kicked out was because of this
but you know it just kind of like got to
the last straw where it was just like
there was so many underlying problems
that like this one thing just really
ticked him off and he was like oh like
um you know like
then you should like leave the house
basically and it was literally like a
school morning so I packed my bags and I
just called my friend and I was like hi
like can you and your mom pick me up and
they picked me up I have my backpack all
my clothes in there like what I packed
my school stuff my binders and I went to
school that morning and then I was like
I'm never going back so then I just
slept over at my friend's house that
night and it just continued and
continued and I just never went back
home and I was still going to high
school at this time in my town and I got
to a point where like I was kind of just
trying to navigate my family life where
I'm living school work and mental health
and doing YouTube because I was making
like maybe like 400 bucks a month that's
like a lot of money you know what I mean
for being a 15 year old making YouTube
videos so I'm trying to do all that so
that's why I started making clean in my
room at 2AM videos is because that was a
popular series while I was like going
through all this stuff you know what I
mean wow and my room was messy because
my mental health wasn't there either
yeah and it got to a point where
actually my school one time well no not
one time my school literally you know
usually you have to get like your mom to
call in when you're in school to be like
hey they're going to be absent today and
get your parents approval right right
did you guys have that yeah I have a
funny story on that later absent slips
yeah no the Colin oh yeah but they were
like oh like my your parents don't have
a call anymore like we trust you like
you we know that you know what you're
doing like it got to that point where I
was like so self-navigating my life at
that age that like even the teachers
were just like do your own thing but
like I just never went back home and I
was just like all right I can't be in
this town anymore like it just reminds
me so much of like
like all my past and stuff like that and
I'll say I need to move on because there
was just like so much that happened in
my life at a young age I feel like but
that's like a whole other thing to dive
into that I like felt like I needed to
change my environment if I wanted
something to happen and I'm so grateful
that my friend let me stay on our couch
for two months
um and I like grinded my YouTube from
that point I was like all right like I
need to be able to make my own money to
be able to support myself you know now
for the two months did they give you two
months or did they say you could stay
here as long as you need to you could
stay here as long as you need to but
that was the summer so it was in the
summer when I was staying with her but
then I was like I can't start this new
school year which was going to be grade
11. I was like I can't start grade 11.
like I just don't know if I'd be able to
do it like my mental health just wasn't
there you know what I mean like I was
like I need something to change because
I was just genuinely like I was
clinically depressed when I was at that
age so you know I was just like I know
that I need to change something because
I can't keep living like this so I saved
up my YouTube money and I moved to two
hours away
the news in the new school year and I
moved two hours away away from my
parents and my sister lived there I have
an older sister so we got an apartment
together and split rent and I think it
was like 600 Canadian a month which is
like 400 and at that point I was making
400 a month from YouTube but I could
barely pay my rent
man hold on Jack we're filming a podcast
right now what's up yo Graham sorry for
calling again I just really wanted to
tell you about today's sponsor epidemic
sound the best tool for all content
creators to soundtrack their content
takedowns and copyright claims are some
of the most frustrating Parts about
being a content creator but also using
some generic overused backtrack can
genuinely ruin a great video thankfully
epidemic has allowed us to use unique
and just genuinely good music in our
videos without having to worry about
them getting demonetized yeah we've been
using epidemic sound for years now and
having access to high quality copyright
free music is essential for any creator
for example epidemic sound is a huge
library of over 35
000 tracks in 90 1000 sound effects with
new tracks being added every single week
all tracks are professionally produced
by a diverse collection of artists and
are exclusive to epidemic sounds you're
not going to find them anywhere else
their personal plan is ideal for Content
creators like us because it covers
everything from YouTube to Twitch to
Instagram to Facebook to so much more so
feel free to use our link Down Below in
the description to get a free 30-day
trial and don't miss out on this
exclusive offer right here on the iced
coffee hour and now with that said let's
get back to the podcast yeah I'm curious
Are there any
legalities about not going to school and
being underage like how does that work
in Canada yeah there's actually a lot
but I
I don't think they did anything about it
to be honest actually yeah no they
didn't do anything about it okay now
what about for your parents do you feel
like oh wait I know now I know why I
know why because when I um actually
stopped going to school so I was still
going to school actually when I moved
when I was when I moved to the new city
I moved into my new apartment I was
still in grade 11 I went to a new high
school and I went from a school of 300
people in high school to like 4 000
people in high school because I moved
from a small town where everyone knew
each other grew up with people for like
years and years and years same teachers
and everything to a school of like three
thousand four thousand people so it was
just a lot to juggle I was like going to
new high school and all this stuff so
um
yeah so I was curious when your father
said for you to leave do you think he
was bluffing do you think he didn't
think that you would actually leave
um yeah because you said it other times
you know what's so funny is you know
when like you were a kid and like your
parents made you mad you're like I'm
gonna run away and you go to your closet
and you patch your backpacks and be like
all right this time I'm actually gonna
do it and then you never leave the house
like you know when your parents I don't
know if y'all had those moments ever as
a kid sure I did were you like I'm gonna
run away but you never actually leave
the house but in your head you're like I
can do it yeah right so like I I've
always had those moments where I'm gonna
do it but I actually did it one day and
I was like
like after like that night be like all
right no seriously my mom did I love my
mommy my mommy called me
um and she was trying to get in contact
with me but I was like kind of
presenting my mom because you know in
correlation it's your parents you know
you you right right if one of those bad
both of them are bad you know so I was
just like she called me she really cared
about me this during this whole process
she's always been there for me but we
just like weren't like we just didn't
have that close of a relationship
because she was working all the time as
I was a kid growing up so it was never
like that so imagine I'm not living with
her anymore it's even more distant but
she's always been there for me so I'm
super grateful for her wow what a story
yeah that's incredible how do you think
your life would have been different had
you stayed that night and not left well
I've never had that question before I'm
curious
yeah that was a good trying I'm trying
trying to expand between like uh that
and like what's your credit scores
zero I know yeah we'll get into that
later my credit score is zero stay tuned
to the end if you guys want to know why
I'm almost 20 years old and I have zero
credit score if I stayed
in White Court Alberta which is like a
small town in Canada I'm Canadian by the
way I grew up in the countryside like
there's no we had a Walmart a McDonald's
in Tim Hortons and what we did for fun
was when we were in high school we would
drive around in trucks and go to the
hockey rink parking lot and hang out in
trucks in each drive through food it's
very Canadian yeah I mean I think that
if I didn't leave that night like I
didn't think of like Plan B I didn't
think plan C I didn't think like oh
maybe this is one of the options I could
finish it out here and go to college I
could
um do this you know what I mean it like
I wasn't thinking about stuff like that
I was thinking more like in the moment
like what can I do right now to make me
happy because I need this to even think
about anything else five years down the
line you know what I mean yeah and so I
was kind of just thinking very
impulsively and like what should I do
next what should I do next so I never
really ever thought about anything other
than the life that I Live Now which is
so crazy to think about but like I was
very like this is my only option I have
to just make it happen like and that
correlates to like what I do now as a
job which is YouTube like I knew that I
needed to make this happen you know and
that sounds like so like what do you
mean you knew that you needed to make
this happen like I knew that like in
order for me to
um
be able to move out and you know
be happy and be able to pay these bills
and stuff like that because I couldn't
be living back at home I knew that like
I had to be able to make my rent and
like
you know what I mean yeah we'll be
successful because I had no one else to
rely on it's the best way I could put it
was that a lot of your motivation for
making YouTube videos no not at all I
started back when I was seven years old
and that was when YouTube just was fresh
there was no money behind it and I
always just knew that I loved to create
as a kid like I was doing it for eight
years unpaid like and I wouldn't say
consistently I would definitely wasn't
posting once a week but I most
definitely was posting every three
months every four months at least at
seven years old I was consistently doing
that cycle until now up I do three
videos a week it was genuinely out of
purely I love to make videos and then
eventually YouTube became what it is and
you could monetize your videos and do
all that stuff and I was like oh my God
this is a bonus I love to do this and
I'm making money and for me like you
always hear people say do something you
love and the fact that I knew that when
I was in grade six because I could see
YouTube growing obviously I wasn't
making money back then but I was
watching people like Bethany Mota and um
Alicia Marie and all these people doing
like these Aeropostale brand deals and
all this stuff and obviously not to the
place that it is now but I was like this
is something people are getting like
like money off of this and I was like oh
my gosh wow like this is so cool yeah
what was your favorite part of the
process of making a YouTube video the
fact that I could be myself and talk to
people and reading the comments like
have friends that's the thing is like
that's my favorite part still to this
day is like I feel like I have friends
and like
that was my favorite thing back then as
well because I didn't have I wasn't
allowed to hang out with people how
strategic were you though because in
addition to making friends and being
yourself there's also an element of like
you have to properly title and thumbnail
and hit on trends like how much work
went in on that behind the scenes zero
really zero yeah now though now zero
zero like if you look at all my
thumbnails there's not one theme that I
follow maybe I'll use the same text but
I do all sorts of different types of
videos and all these one like a couple
months ago I just turned the video
camera I've done this a couple times I
turned the video camera on I just start
talking for 15 minutes no Cuts nothing
and I'll just put it up there and I'll
be talking about the most random stuff
or I'll sit and cry and be like guys
like I'm about to burn out and I won't
cut the video
that is crazy or I'll do videos like um
staying at the worst rate in the most
expensive hotel in New York City and
have it all like highly edited or I'll
just like do like a regular Vlog you
know there's all or mukbangs like
anything do you think you're more
comfortable in front of the camera than
you are in a group of people oh my God a
million to ten percent yeah I see this
all the time that's why I don't go to
any like group events I don't do any
group brand trips I don't go to
Coachella like for me I feel so anxious
and like awkward in a group of people
like I feel like I can't talk so being
in front of just the camera like that's
my being my full self it's hard to
picture you being like shy in a group of
people because you seem so extroverted
when we're talking right now really yes
yeah oh it's fake it's all fake it's
impressive I like think that I'm so
terrible in groups of people like that's
actually one of my biggest insecurities
is that yeah I'm not good in a group
like I can't
that's what it is maybe social anxiety
but yeah I thought it takes a lot of
practice like the more I stay home and
make YouTube videos the more I go out
and realize like what am I doing it's a
muscle it's a hundred percent I forget
how to talk yeah and then I get so
self-conscious like am I holding my arms
the right way and am I am I looking am I
making it too much everything yeah
whereas when you're filming all the time
you get really used to filming you just
look at the camera and just talk and now
this is easier than going out and then
no you just go out all the time and then
right that yes it is like a muscle and
then I can film see this is the thing
for me I have something called the spam
account on my Instagram and I go on
there and I will spam the stories and
put 20 on there a day because I will
just record and just talk about all my
thoughts which is crazy I have friends
too now like I've made friends now okay
like it's not just this stuff but you
know sometimes it's just more convenient
to just go on there talk about
everything that's happening that I'm
feeling in the moment be like oh I'm so
upset because I forgot that she's at the
grocery store and this man said this to
me you know that maybe you tell your mom
about but I posted on there and then I
get instant people dming me and telling
me their thoughts and I feel like I'm
just texting a bunch of friends at the
same time I did one video it was
spending one thousand dollars because I
got suspended from high school and like
I
um did I actually spend a thousand
dollars no I didn't actually spend a
thousand dollars it was just a clickbait
title you don't even got to do what
you're gonna do I I can't remember
anymore I can't remember but I did that
and I got my hair dyed for the first
time and that's actually how the spam
account started was because I got my
tattoo but I didn't want my parents to
see my tattoo so I was like Hey guys if
you guys want to see my tattoo I posted
it on my private Instagram and you have
to request to follow it and so every
single request I accepted because I had
to make sure it wasn't my siblings or my
parents you look through everybody yeah
because what was it keep in mind I only
had like
I wasn't at the scale that I am today so
I could see everyone you know we were
really close yeah so I posted my tattoo
on there and that's what the spam
account is now today it started that's
how it started but anyways yeah I did
all of that and then I made another one
an Instagram batty one and then that one
I remember got like 2.5 million views in
the first I don't know like week or so
and I was like oh my gosh wow and then
it kept going and it kept going it kept
going and my Instagram picture hit a
hundred thousand likes and I was 15
years old with only maybe 15 000
followers on Instagram like that's crazy
you know this is my first blow up I'm
used to getting maybe like five thousand
four thousand on Instagram which is a
lot but to get a hundred thousand the
next week like what the how are you
mentally prepared to handle that at 15
like so many people and so many eyeballs
watching you and feeling that pressure
to make everyone happy see I never I
still to this day don't feel like
anyone's watching me so I never felt a
pressure of like oh my God that many
people are now are watching me it was
always like I still read every single
comment like I try to read every single
comment now still like if you go to my
YouTube channel all the likes I mean all
my recent videos my comments will always
be hearted because like
I actually love feeling there's some
like there's somebody there anyways so
when that all happened like it didn't
feel like there was more people it just
felt like I
was just reading more comments I don't
know how to explain it and it was just
so supportive you know what I mean so it
never felt like it was like more eyes on
me it was like oh my God like more love
Yeah my rebellious phase was gonna tell
you earlier when you're talking about
like calling in I I know I've done this
before Jack but um when I got my
driver's license I'd pretend to be my
mom on the phone so I could ditch and go
to work because all I wanted to do was
work I didn't care about going to school
so I would call in I'll do I'll do the
impression
hi I'm calling on behalf of Graham he's
not feeling that well but uh he'll be in
tomorrow thanks to like like that's kind
of leave a little voicemail yeah yeah
actually one of my goals this year that
I really am actually holy crap it's
almost the end of the year now this was
one of my New Year's resolutions was to
uh tap into minimalism more and stop
getting like buying so many new things
and because I used to have a room yeah
full of clothes shopping mall right uh
yeah I do wear some shopping hauls and
stuff like that but I literally used to
have a closet that was dedicated to a
room you know what I mean but now I only
have like maybe like 20 shirts and like
10 pants yeah why did you want to do
minimalism just because I used to have a
series that was cleaning my room at 2
A.M and that was on like reflective on
my mental health like I was just all
over the place you know what I mean and
so you know what I mean like when you're
thinking about so many things you can't
keep your room clean personally that's
me and I was like oh my gosh you always
hear that people say like oh your
environment is what matters a lot for
your mental health and I was on a
mission to make my mental health
so I was like okay like I need to stop
making a mess so I was like how do I
stop making mess maybe stop buying so
many things maybe stop keeping so much
clutter around your house because you're
making a mess so then I was like okay
let's get into minimalism interesting
when did you move to New York I moved to
New York
the beginning of this year so when I was
18. how was that process how did you
find out where to live and moving to a
new city in New York uh I knew one girl
from Tick Tock I had like one friend
yeah but that's it so how did you go
about moving to a new city I wouldn't
have the courage to have done that at
18. I'm moving in the past like three
years do you think that moving to New
York has helped your channel in what way
it's so crazy how much my life has
changed in the past year just from
living in New York City and that doesn't
mean just because I'm in New York City I
make New York Vlogs just like people
commenting they're like oh my God you
seem so much happier in New York than
you did living in La like I can see it
in you and that reflected on like my
videos I've noticed New York is really
good for Content Elliott Choi too yeah I
saw you guys podcasted him yeah yeah so
cool there's something magic about New
York where I feel like it's good for
Vlogs everyone just wants to know what
it's like to live in New York right yeah
before I moved to New York I was like
okay I need to make sure I Vlog in New
York because I tried to search up Vlogs
and I was like nobody really captions
captures New York I want to know what is
it like living there yeah I feel like
that was pretty instrumental for Casey
neistat though yes it was like the whole
New York thing because he really
accurately documented I don't know I've
never been there but I feel like it was
accurately documented yeah I've seen the
Venice Vlogs not the same yeah yeah I
never watched them but I'm so glad he's
back in the city now yeah something
about that I love Casey neistat he
inspires me so much yeah why do you
think so many people resonate with the
living alone aspect how did you come up
with that were you the first one to do
living alone I'm I'm definitely not the
first one to be living alone
um but like but posting that in YouTube
is a title because I noticed once your
video took off living alone I see
everyone else now putting living alone
yeah maybe it is a trend now but I think
that it's just like we've transitioned
so much in YouTube from I don't people
just love to see what people do every
single day now you know you don't have
to do some crazy stuff you don't have to
have anything High productive uh
production it's just like we want to see
what you do day to day and what's your
schedule like my schedule oh now we're
getting into the gram questions it's
different every single day this is
different every single day um I would
say the only thing that stays routine
not right now though because like I'm
traveling but uh usually when I'm back
at home I'm not always on it I want to
say I'm not like
but I try to wake up early there's no
strict bedtime or anything like that but
one thing that I've been doing every
day for a while is like going on a run
but I can't even say that I go on a run
sometimes I'm so lazy I'm like early
just go down there on the treadmill for
a minute you know but routine
um and then my day starts and then it
ends that's literally the only thing
that I make sure I do every single day
is those two things and how do you
decide what to film like what do you
feel yeah because you post three times a
week how do you decide in this is there
ever a point where like oh man I gotta
do something today do something in what
way like film a topic or I have to
coming up with the video ideas oh come
in with the video ideas yeah oh I have a
vault of them I've never ran out of a
video idea in my life oh that sounds so
cocky I've never run out of a video to
do my life guys so that's it yeah what's
an example of like some ideas that you
have my brain literally is always
flowing with video ideas I can look at
anything and be like all right let's do
that let's do that let's yeah I have a
whole notion page that has all these
videos ideas in it and every time I've
actually never looked at this because I
never draw blank but it just is nice to
just write it down to have the safety of
like oh I have that written down I know
never really do it like that anyways
it's more like I just look at anything
and there's a video idea in my head so
let's say you're in this in this podcast
room right now you're like looking
around analyzing the room you see these
light fixtures you see whatever what
type of video idea would you come up
with well I feel I feel like okay I'm a
robot like tell me how this process
works um
like right now I wouldn't I would be
thinking oh I need to start a podcast I
don't know it's just like no shipping so
I'm like I think I need to start a
podcast that's what I'm thinking yes do
it you'd be great at like Graham said
you'd be great yeah 100 no yes yeah I
just talk myself in circles that's great
well that's people will love it sorry
why do you think you'll be bad
because I just feel like it's just like
really who actually gives I feel like
everyone's starting podcasts now but and
I think about it and I'm like
everyone else's podcast would be better
than mine like why would who would want
to hear me just like Babble for an hour
straight like let's be real here my like
don't do that well the thing is you
don't have to babble like you can talk
for like just don't Babble and cut it
down to 30. yeah like that's what we do
it's like okay so obviously there are
different styles of editing podcasts
some people leave up the entire raw
podcast that's crazy what we do is we
treat it like a YouTube video so we have
like segments we cut it up and we try to
have a little hook like Graham said
every 10 or 15 minutes so you can Babble
for 90 minutes and cut it down like you
would edit a YouTube video and structure
it right you can make anything out of 90
minutes of Rob sometimes I like the like
the weird pauses in between and the
fully uncut version of a podcast because
it seems like a conversation yeah oh
also people's expectation of
entertainment value is severely
diminished in podcast and I will say
that openly having a podcast their
expectation of how much they need to be
entertained way lower because they're
listening to you at the gym they're not
going to change it it's really yes
they're listening to you in the car when
they're driving it's it's like a
different style of commitment than
actively watching a YouTube video that
needs to have like visuals jumping out
at you every few minutes seconds or
tingling right now I'm like because I
think about it I'm like no because
I don't want to talk for an hour and
people listen and be like oh I didn't
think I I'm so used to my being
entertaining like she's so [ __ ]
boring because they watch a 15 minute
video and they're like wow because it's
just like five hours of footage go into
10 minutes so the fact that you're
listening to me an hour straight like
what am I doing yeah what I would do is
try three episodes and just see if you
like it and maybe you try it and you
realize this sucks it's just like I
don't enjoy this case no I don't think
so yeah but I would do it everyone is
starting podcasts now but I believe that
that is uh just it's gonna be moving in
that direction really yeah that's kind
of what stops me is because I'm like oh
like no we don't need another one no but
here's what I'm thinking here's here's
where it's going it seems like we're
going in the direction of the middle
content of like five to 20 minutes is
disappearing people either want 30 to 60
seconds or an hour I agree that's and so
it's like you have to adapt so what I
would do for you is do the the podcast
and then a lot of these little shorts
but throw in obviously don't stop the
videos you're making but just supplement
them with shorts y'all heard that here
when I stopped posting YouTube videos go
to Graham Stephen's comments because he
reads every single one of his comments
and tell him why is she did you say that
I thought was that very ground yeah
but grin
but anyways yeah like I don't I don't
know I've never ran drive an idea which
I'm so grateful for but I think it's
also because I don't think of YouTube
videos as a job like I think of it as
what fun am I gonna do today and take
people along with me so she's like I
just went to the middle of the ocean
um for like six days I got stuck in the
middle of the ocean because I thought
it'd be so fun to get go to the middle
of the ocean and like be alone again
then I was like let's take them with me
make a little challenge for both of us
yeah but but how has it changed now that
this is your way of making money because
before you're doing it for fun how has
that changed the dynamic between the
content that you make your audience but
it's also like supporting you too I mean
I think that there's just a lot more
business behind it now you know what I
mean there's like brand deals and all
that stuff so you know I got to think of
like that side and like my clothing line
and like I would still be making these
videos without the money side of it so I
don't try to think about that part too
much to me I don't think of it as oh I
need to not post this video because it's
just not going to get as many views or
it might flunk my channel to me it's
like put out whatever I want because the
more content the better so it doesn't
really matter how strategic I do it
because I'm not gonna not put out a
video because I think it's not going to
do well who cares if it doesn't well I
have two more videos going up this week
that may do well anyways I just want to
do whatever I want that's so interesting
because at least in in the finance
sector at least what I've noticed across
the years
uh you are only allowed for the
algorithm two bad performing videos in a
row before it diminishes the return of
the third video so all of a sudden now I
can't reach as many people in the third
video because I have two bad ones in a
row and I tested this throughout five
channels now and so every time I get one
bad performing video that's pretend I
know the next one has to be at least
like a five oh so you have to
strategically think yes wow that's so
crazy but I'm a numbers person so I like
I look at the algorithm throughout the
day like I don't even have YouTube
Studio on my phone really I don't check
my analytics what I'm just like to me
like I make the best videos when I'm
happy and like if I'm checking my
analytics I'm not gonna be happy and I'm
gonna think too hard so like if I'm
happy I know my videos do well so all I
have to care about is if I'm like liking
my videos and if I'm having fun if I'm
having fun I know my videos are doing
well and if it doesn't I have faith that
like people will always come back one
day you know what I mean well that's way
more sustainable than my math yeah yeah
so much mine is mine is like a race
where it's like at the 15 minute Mark I
check it I analyze the click-through
rate I I look at the number of comments
I'm getting I I compare that to the last
10 videos that I posted I'm like how
could I improve it I tweak videos
throughout the first few hours to I
optimize everything well because I think
sometimes with YouTube it's just like
you post a video and it's 10 out of 10
but then a month later it's one out of
ten and the reason why is because you
post content that people aren't used to
so they don't want to click on it
initially but it broadens your audience
and next you know that video is viral
but I think the thing with me is I've
posted now I think almost 1500 videos
across oh wait yeah your thing is
different though so yeah I was talking
about my category yeah so I know like if
this video is a 10 but it should have
been a two I messed up and then I had
but some of my posts I'm like I know
it's gonna do really bad but over a year
it'll do fantastic so I know that going
in like how well like for for me it's
weird real estate videos always do
incredibly well stock market videos do
okay any sort of long tail video like
index funds or passive income dude
horrible so I have like a ranking system
in terms of topics that people want to
watch yeah you have this whole algorithm
in your head of how your channel works
yeah
that's so cool no for me my most viral
video was ranked a 10 out of 10.
like it bumped its way up yeah which one
is that uh it was my Euphoria cat like I
recreated Cassie from euphoria's
um routine and the reason why I got that
video idea was because I was watching
Euphoria and I saw her use all those
beauty products and I was like that's
the video I was gonna do but it took me
four months to actually act on it but I
had that in the vault and I was like
right now's the time and I filmed it all
and then I like just knew that I needed
to post it now because it was the
Euphoria season finale and I posted it
and boom from zero to like 10 million
views in wow like a couple weeks so use
your exact products basically yeah her
exact products like your makeup uh no it
went from like I literally from shaver
to
um curlers to face ice rollers to lotion
to like the exact motions to the exact
time she woke up at 4am like the exact
editing like I literally edited the big
intro of that video to be exactly like
how Euphoria was produced I put the same
it was like everything 15 minutes how
much did you make from that video do you
know
no I don't know okay I actually don't
have your YouTube studio app I would say
oh let me check a million views I'm
gonna guess too Beauty I'll say
70 no 80. it's not Finance it's not
finance my guess was probably 45 000. no
makeup's probably a four to seven dollar
CPM it's my guess CPM yeah or RPM RPM oh
why what's CPM of beauty probably four
to seven dollars so for every thousand
views you get what why what do you think
whatever it is
most likely YouTube Studio I'm genuinely
curious now I don't have it I tell
everyone delete YouTube Studio off your
phone because as a YouTuber if I hang
out with YouTubers we're all always on
the YouTube Studio refreshing the 10 out
of 10. and I'm just like y'all stop
checking it's so funny what I love to do
is get together with everybody and be
like yo I'll show you mine you show me
yours and then we we all SWAP phones and
we're like we look at it like sift
through it I'm like okay I want okay
that one let me see yours and we'll swap
phones around and we'll look here I love
it oh my gosh yeah
I would be like oh my God [ __ ] I'm doing
[ __ ] ah how is your income sources
broken down like how does it work is it
is it sponsorships at the top and then
ad Revenue I would say sponsorships is
like uh 90 okay and then 10 is AdSense
which is actually so good because and
that means that like I'm not motivated
to make a viral video for the AdSense
I'm just motivated to make videos
because I want to make videos that I
want to make yeah but that's how my
YouTube is broken down but like overall
everything
um
I don't know do you like stocks count
and stuff like that absolutely I think
so right now I'm not making money off
stocks making money off stocks you
asking me on my portfolio when I get my
paycheck I would say 85 of that gets
invested and I've been doing that since
I was 18. and what does it get invested
in index funds so when I was first 18
though the first thing I invested in was
crypto
for six months I put like 100 of my
paycheck into crypto because I knew that
like it was gonna it went down even more
which is worse but I just knew that like
that was the first thing I wanted to do
just try to get in it as early as I can
because everyone always says like just
stop waiting you know what I mean so I
did that and then I stopped which I
haven't looked at that in a long time
because for me that's something long
term like I put it away it's gone it's
out of my head it's not even my money
anymore and so I plan on having that in
there for I don't even know how long you
don't even know how long but the people
in the crypto are gonna be like could
you tell us what you bought I'm just
guessing Bitcoin ethereum Bitcoin and
ethereum okay yeah I didn't play around
with any of that small stuff because
like I'm not somebody that's like into
that that much you know what I mean I
kind of just want to yeah yeah I five
percent in Bitcoin ethereum 50 50 split
if it does nothing I don't care if it
goes up then hey a minute right yeah you
just kind of put in and forget about it
that's how I feel and then
um I would say mostly just index funds
is like
80 of my portfolio that's great because
I can't buy real estate I don't have a
credit score yeah and what's your team
look like is it just do you and editors
I have me I have my manager Charlie
she's been with me since I was 16.
um I have my coordinator I have my
graphics editor Kaylee she does all the
drawings on my videos I have my two
editors that do the rough cuts and the
music Libby and Daniela and then I also
have you know I actually just onboarded
a lawyer because I feel like now as
things get a little bit crazier maybe I
should be protected I feel like people
always yeah like you don't even feel
that I've been an industry longer tell
me that and then I have like my YouTube
manager and my assistant so yeah wow
there's a lot of people and like I know
a lot of people like usually don't have
people but for me I'm just like like no
there's so much help that goes behind
here like I want to be able to be the
person I am it's so odd because there's
someone just like looking in your
channel I just imagine it's you on a
camera just vlogging and then just like
at night uploading rough cuts for like
three hours four hours post no not at
all I've I've had like my I've had an
editor I've had a team obviously not to
this size but I've always had a team
since I was like 16.
wow and it that doesn't mean that I've
always had an editor though like I've
always I just like slowly um as like I
like it progresses
um I'll edit a little bit less but like
yeah I've always had people helping
which I'm so grateful for are all of
your employees in New York or do they
work remotely no I actually only have I
only just got an assistant like um a
month ago but my editor is one of them's
in Spain one of them's in Canada one's
of them San Diego all over the world but
you don't talk to them too much you
probably have someone that stands in
between you like you and them or no I
talk to all of them directly really so
you don't have somebody that's just kind
of like running like the Ops of
everything and it's just I have my whole
entire iMessage is literally every
single one of my employees it's so bad
it's not my mom or anything sorry Mom
but it's every single one of my
employees my uh this is my group chat
for my managers my group chat managers
assistant assistant editor editor editor
manager business managers YouTube
manager wow
that's crazy that is crazy I should
probably get another phone
I do actually yeah oh my God Jack and
look see
it's not there
that makes me feel good I have I have
Alex amazing you pinned my assistant and
then I don't know what this is my
assistant Jack has more people working
for him than I do oh wow wow yeah I love
having a team it's so nice yeah I really
love it yes I like just having a small
like little family Grim you don't like
the stress of hiring that's the thing he
doesn't like giving someone else his
responsibility because he's so nervous
it will not get done because he says he
runs a tight ship to the to the quality
and standards that he has well the thing
is you used to edit your videos you
handed off the editing and you haven't
regretted it you love it so it's just
the the nervousness of going taking that
first step taking that first step I'm
also on that's the hardest once the step
has been made and you're you're on your
stride yeah you know that's true then
it's nice yeah for me I always think
about it like you know what if I'm
juggling a million things I can't
actually be good at anything if I hire
somebody that's good at one thing
they're gonna do a better job than me
that's true that's how I always think
specialization yes so where do you want
to take this over the next like 10 years
like what what's your grand and plan for
everything I feel like you have to have
some dream or vision of where you see
yourself like 10 years from now I don't
really
do you not think about it much no I
never do really
not really I don't really care I am in
10 years because I'm like
I'm happy right now I keep living today
over and over and over again I always
say like oh I wish I was 17 or did it uh
like I don't know
I really like I don't I don't try to
think too much of the future because why
would I think about that when I'm
enjoying it right now you know what I
mean and I feel like a lot of people
think too 10 years later actually we're
not even getting to that but yeah I just
really enjoy my day-to-day life right
now yeah do you have any goals
um yeah of course I have like career
goals and stuff like that like I would
love to be able to take um alcohol like
my clothing and was gonna develop more
into like wellness and mental health and
stuff I want to develop that Adventure
into something bigger and like I want to
be able to one day make a mental health
foundation and also like do a beauty
brand and courses and all that stuff but
I don't want to get in this for six
specifics of what my goals are now you
mentioned New Year's uh resolutions
earlier do you have anything coming up
for 2023 that you could share oh oh I
haven't thought about that yet actually
but I think one of my biggest things is
um
my two biggest things would be to be a
better leader
um and create a really good team and
also Build a Better Community those are
my two biggest things because my goal
ever since I started my YouTube channel
way back then was you know hit the 2
million subscribers and then I was like
okay average this many views of video
like that was always my dream and after
I've hit those numbers I'm like okay I
can't keep chasing numbers like I'm done
with that like let me do other things
now so how do you think you could be a
better leader
um honestly just a lot more
communication I feel like because I feel
like since doing YouTube it's a very
self-employed thing so a lot of things
are in your head and you know the
certain way you want to do it you know
and people aren't in your head so being
able to convey that to other people but
also just like yeah I would say that's
that's it yeah
what I've observed that I really admire
because it's something I've actually
personally been working on for a long
time in my life I've never mentioned it
on the podcast something I've always
been working on is trying to be present
in my life because it's hard for me to
enter a room and to not be thinking
about so many things other than just
what exactly is happening in that exact
room at that time and it seems like
you've done a good job about that you
don't think too much about the future
you don't think too much about the past
you said you could relive this exact day
over and over and over again and I think
that's cool and I definitely admire that
something I would like to get yeah and
that's actually one of the reasons why
I'm such a uh I don't think that I'm a
very good leader right now is because I
don't think too much in the future at
all so people will ask me when are you
gonna get this done when you get this
done like you know um do you need me to
come in tomorrow all this up and I can't
tell them because it's just all in my
head and like I just know that I need to
do it and it's just gonna happen when I
in the moment I'm gonna do it you know I
don't be thinking too much about how
it's gonna happen I just think your
biggest weaknesses I think that my
biggest weakness is
I've never thought about this I feel
like it's a job interview wow what is
your biggest strength yeah what are you
saying no no let's start with the
weakness yeah you're too giving
mine's my calves your calves are your
biggest weakness my babies that's why I
will maintain that I cannot get my
calves bigger you don't try this guy
never hits Leg Day Ever he makes fun of
me if I hit leg day I love will you guys
weight lift yes yeah I used to weight
lift I love fun it's great yeah yeah
it's very therapeutic it's my favorite
form of working out
um okay anyways my biggest weakness oh
this is so cliche but I'm a terrible
communicator
terrible in what way like I can't convey
my thoughts like I'm very bad at telling
somebody what I'm thinking so a lot of
the times I will bottle it all up and
I'll be something like let's say you're
working in a team and the problem will
happen or like you know what I mean
there's a block in the road I will just
literally stare there and like analyze
everything in my head and try to fix all
these problems in my head without
telling people that there's a problem or
like
communicating how I feel which like in a
team setting that's important you know
like if you don't think something's
going well being able to explain hey I
think that this maybe needs to be
changed I won't say anything it's just
gonna be all in my head and I'll try to
figure out on my own so you don't know
what a team is I'm not confrontational
at all that's where I think you need to
hire somebody to be confrontational for
you because then it's not you it's the
other person they make it that's a good
point but I want to be somebody that can
do that you know what I mean okay
because like let's say your boss was
gonna like like me like wanted to tell
you to do something better imagine your
boss got like I mean I say your boss but
like we're all here doing this but was
like oh like you need to I don't know
fold this better if he got the manager
was like hey um Derek said you need to
fold this better it's just gonna be like
oh well they don't say Derek
they say hey you need to build this bed
they're not going to throw someone under
the bus
so if you're out at a restaurant and you
order the salmon okay and they bring you
like the white fish oh 100 I'm gonna be
able to be late excuse me ma'am I'm so
sorry but like yeah I'd be like sorry
I'm so sorry like I don't know if you
heard but like I must have said it wrong
but I could I actually get this I will
do that but when it comes to directly to
somebody about something they've done or
you know something that I've done I
can't do it I don't know why so great I
am the exact opposite I will if
something's going on between my friends
and I I will go up to him it's super
uncomfortable but I will have that talk
with them but at a restaurant if I order
something and I'm with my mom or my
Jewish Grandpa game over they will just
start raising hell in the restaurant if
something's going on we're completely
opposites that's funny yeah I had no
problem with that without a restaurant
yeah what if you got that from Jason
oppenheim he's very much that he is yeah
he's he's Cut Throat when it comes to
that if if the temperature
but here's the temperature yes but it
was freezing cold Jason could walk into
a restaurant and I I don't want to make
it seem like I'm talking anything back
because I I respect it a lot you really
are Jason yes but he would walk in and
sometimes it would be just too cold and
he had no problem saying like hey it's
kind of cold in here could you raise the
temperature wait tell me why I don't
know what's too hot or if you've done
that before yeah not in a restaurant or
anything like with that like in my
friend's house oh okay oh okay okay okay
okay you know my proudest moment is when
the music is too loud
I'm sorry but I'm somebody who that is a
sucker for Ambiance yeah like that
affects me so much it's like the
background music anyways but yeah that's
my biggest weakness what's her is Jack
my biggest weakness
I have to think about that you answer
first and then I'll answer
um I'm probably I probably overthink
everything and I'm probably too Hands-On
I'm too micromanaging of everything but
so it gets it done stupid deadlines I'm
really hard on really I miss every
deadline of mine oh no mine has to be
done like you know I'm getting better
but uh I'm very much a sticker and now I
like deadlines ahead of deadlines I'm
like if we don't hit this deadline we're
gonna miss this one so we gotta like hit
this probably bad but no I'm like um hey
so I actually can't do this can we move
it till next week end of week
that's I do similar things I figured out
my weakness I think it's I can I can't
really do something like half effort I'm
either 100 000 effort or no effort I
either care about something a ton or I
don't so it's hard for me to like find
that middle ground and be like you know
I'm gonna allocate like a few hours my
day to this it's either like my entire
day spent doing this or I don't even
think about it yeah so I feel like I'm
kind of the same way All or Nothing
person yeah oh yeah I have a house
viewing tomorrow because I'm going to
actually by the time this podcast is up
I will probably be living in my new
apartment
um I just moved into a new New York City
apartment and I have to go View and meet
with the owners tomorrow yeah I'm
excited moving in part of your team yes
I'm my editor is gonna live with me as
well and I'm super super super excited
wow so you're no longer alone no longer
alone actually I'm gonna be alone for a
little bit because they don't move until
they're out of college because they're
both still in college okay but
and next thing you know I'm going to be
living with roommates he said it was a
penthouse yes it is the penthouse wow
which is so crazy this is like literally
insane like I never thought that this
would happen so I just want to say thank
you to everyone watching oh my God yeah
but it turns into like now an office too
that's the way I look at it
when I was like I need to do this I'm
gonna start my podcast now because I
have enough room for it do it yeah do it
how about this start the podcast if you
actually do it by the time we post I
will link it in the description my
podcast the podcast uh should I start a
podcast yeah start the podcast just try
a couple episodes okay just a couple
we'll see just do it all right you're
not gonna regret it by the way guys I
literally I just want to say this is
that I was having real estate problems
and didn't know because I didn't have a
credit score and I was having so many
issues and I was like ah and I caught
ground got on a phone call and he
coached me through the whole thing so we
need to think oh yeah yes I was like
literally having a crisis and I was like
Graham I don't know what to do I think
I'm gonna get screwed over and help me
with everything and he got it it was a
very simple solution to that
um no it's not a complicated it wasn't
complicated very easy so thank you guys
everyone everyone give this video a
thumbs up and say w gram in the comments
if we want to thank Graham now you gotta
adopt that W's W gram in the chat I
don't know all right anyway so with that
said thank you so much oh I really
appreciate it uh make sure to get a free
stock sign up at public.com Jack JLS
check me ma'am thank you so much for
tuning in and until next time thank you
bye